the first song I ever wrote I was about
five or six I made it for my mom and I
would sing it to her when I was around
the house and I would ask her mum please
can I keep your dress please keep your
shoes can you please I just wanted to be
a phrase how really I always start with
lyrics it's always when something
significant happens I take it I write it
down and when I go into the studio I
then put the words to melody and if I
still feel the same way about the the
words that I've written that I feel like
I should definitely carry on with the
story everything I write about is is
quite personal and it's all very much
biographical so I'm more inspired by
words than by melodies and then I'd like
to call my music dance crying because
they're all quite sad stories in a way
but then with the production I want it
to be more pop and I want it to be
something that people can dance to I
guess my writing process is kind of
crazy I write so many songs and out of
ten I like one oh I wish every homesick
is well a feeling and it was one that I
was definitely feeling towards the end
of writing the album when I spend so
much time on the road and I spend so
much time away from home and I'm
traveling so much it's really when I'm
in a hot place like LA and it starts
raining that I miss London the most and
it's you know you spend so much time
away and it's like the the things that
you hate about home and the ones that
you miss the most so the bad weather was
definitely I guess that the main
influence behind everything and singing
about that the reason you know you make
all these little sacrifices is to kind
of make your dreams come true and you
work pretty hard because this is
something that you've you've always
wanted but there's no denying that you
occasionally get home second you do miss
that
with all the features that I've done
I've always wanted to work with people
that did something quite different to
what I do so when I do come together
with them it's it's still quite distinct
what I'm able to bring to the table I
was really lucky I got to work and write
it with Chris Martin and I was in London
prior to going to to LA to write and I
was in a meeting and somebody had asked
me who I would love to work with and I
said oh I would love to get in the
studio with Chris Martin it was more
just me just putting it out there into
the world and I didn't expect for for
one of the lovely women who were in the
meeting and she said oh I work really
closely with Coldplay why didn't he send
me some of the songs from your album and
I can send him to Chris he's very busy
but we can see maybe make something work
and I was like okay cool so I chose a
few songs on the album and I sent them
over and I just get an email going why
didn't you go down to the studio and go
meet Chris and play him some stuff and I
was like okay cool I don't really think
anything was going to come of it
and so I went to the studio and just sat
there me Chris and his engineer Bill and
we just listened to all the songs in the
album and what I was nervous just kind
of playing all the songs it was also
really interesting to kind of get
feedback from someone who I guess in a
way makes popular music but it's so
different to the kind of music that I
make and just to hear hear their opinion
especially as an artist that I
appreciate and admire and he listened to
everything and he was like great why
don't we just try and write something
else but for the album and I was like
right now he was like yeah let's do it
and he just sat on the piano and it was
kind of crazy hearing Chris play play
the keys because the second he start
playing I was like arthas's there's
Coldplay someone who'd been hearing on
the radio I guess your whole life
playing less than a meter away from
mirrors is really surreal
I I had a session the next day so why I
left and we kind of left her that he
would write some of it and I would write
some of it and we could come back
together and put our ideas but when I
left I also thought I was never going to
come back so I was kind of mentally
prepared to just write it on my own and
so I just dropped him a text and I was
like okay I have this idea and I have
this time free I know you're busy maybe
you could we could get back in together
he's like yeah come down on on Wednesday
and let's finish the song and we wrote
the whole song Chris started playing
some chords on the piano and we just
went from there we had mics set up in
the room and I was just humming melodies
and trying to see what sounds good and
we were making up different parts and I
guess some of it sounded like words some
of it was just mumbling but it was it's
probably the first time I'd ever I'd
ever done a song based on melody to
begin where they knew what the concept
was going to be of it seeing as you know
we'd already come up with a title for
home second I knew what I was gonna
write about that it was the first time
that I just kind of went on the basis of
melody and it was really what kind of
drove the song oh and I went in and I
recorded it and then I I kind I just
went please because will you sing on it
because the whole time when we were
writing it we were singing it together
and it just felt so weird when I went
into the to the booth and sang it on my
own and he agreed to do it and that's
really how it how it came about maybe it
was probably the last song to finish off
the album it was really that last trip
to LA that I made where when I hopped on
the plane back to London I was like okay
I feel like I'm done with the album
so this elements all been just very
personal I feel like I've had a lot to
say just just because I never had the
opportunity to really just put it down
and try and tell a story and and you
know kind of create a project like that
like an album and be able to allow the
fans and listeners to really get to know
me on a more personal level so I think I
really just had the opportunity to
travel and I learned to be more open and
learn to not be so afraid of my own
thoughts and speak up about just things
that I felt were really personal to me
especially when I would walk in a room
with producers and songwriters that I'd
never worked with before it really
taught me to be more confident and just
go out there and just really say what I
felt and not and not be embarrassed and
not be afraid of it and I guess I just
learned that that the only person that
was gonna get a real on a song out for
me was me but that's when I feel like I
found clarity and I was really able to
just write but I tend to write quite
quickly but this this one just felt
really easy I guess it was it was just
the perfect closing song
[Music]